welcome back in this lesson you'll be
developing your very own portfolio page
which you'll be able to share with the
world I know the layout looks different
than what you did before in the first
lesson but don't worry I'll be helping
you with an approach that will make your
life easier by creating a CSS framework
that you can use in this project in
future projects you'll be able to make
beautiful pages like this without any
problem along the way you'll be
developing your portfolio following
responsive design principles which means
that your website is going to look great
for everyone regardless of their device
are you ready to get started